new mentality a new culture of hospitals
working with one another both within the
public system as well as the private
system this is going to be all hands on
deck
this is everybody helping everyone else
one Hospital gets overwhelmed the other
hospitals have to have to flex to help
that hospital and vice versa
New York hospitals gearing up for a
surge of new patients in the coming
weeks as state and city leaders fight to
flatten the curve on the corona virus
pandemic the number of deaths rising
dramatically in New York in just the
past several days most of them in New
York City David Lee Miller is live for
us in Manhattan this morning where a
makeshift field hospital is being built
in Central Park David Lee
Sandra New Yorkers are very jaded Bunch
now many simply cannot believe what they
see taking place in Central Park behind
me a ten-city
temporary hospital being constructed the
location here directly across the street
from New York's Mount Sinai Hospital a
hospital here like so many struggling to
cope with the increasing number of virus
patients the roadway separating the
hospital and Central Park Fifth Avenue a
street that has some of the most
expensive real estate in the world now
here at this location in Central Park
since Sunday this tent city has been
under construction by the time it's done
on Tuesday there will be 14 tents that
have been constructed about half that
many have now been set up this is the
work of a group called Samaritan's Purse
based in north carolina they have
brought with them as many as 16 health
care professionals including doctors
nurses and paramedics Mayor Bill de
Blasio says he's grateful for the help
we're gonna be using every place we need
to use to help people a Mount Sinai
Hospital working with the organization
named Samaritan's Purse
is creating a 68 bed field hospital so
this is the kind of thing you will see
now as this crisis develops and deepens
among the 68 beds that the mayor talked
about 10 will be intensive care capable
equipped with ventilators New York
continues the race against time to
increase the total number of hospital
beds before the virus reaches its apex
and other help has already arrived the
plane from China touched down at New
York's JFK Airport on board more than
100,000 n95 masks 1.8 million surgical
masks and gowns and more than a million
gloves the supplies were brought here as
part of a White House led project called
Project air bridge a partnership of the
federal government and private industry
FEMA will distribute supplies to the New
York region as well as other high-risk
areas and the measures that have been
input in place up by both the city and
the state they do appear to be making a
difference the latest statistics show
that the number of hospitalizations are
now doubling at a rate of only if you
will only double every six days
meanwhile the death rate though
continues to rise Sandra what a sight
that is right in the middle of New York
City in New York's Central Park David
Lee Miller thank you